on vous parle des photos radars un sujet
toujours très contreversé à chaque fois
qu'on en parle on a des tonnes de
courriels vont vous invite à chaque fois
nous écrit ça nous fait plaisir et
pascal québec s'apprête donc en
installer des nouveaux d'un bout à
l'autre du québec et tout
particulièrement ici dans la région de
mons
oui il y en aura eu juste derrière moi
patrice son coin des boulevards gaétan
boucher et cousines ont pour bien
comprendre les packs pour le grand
montréal regardons une carte donc en
montérégie ce sera ce seront 28 nouveaux
emplacements 8 dans l'agglo
l'agglomération de longueuil uniquement
dans les laurentides 5 laval ou 6 5 et 6
ont un petit peu plus loin dans
lanaudière ce sera onze emplacements
nouveau si vous voulez connaître les
emplacements très très précisément
rendez vous sur le site web du ministère
des transports
une façon pour québec aussi de
reconnaître et d'avouer de me dire que
ce programme la marche depuis son
implantation depuis 2009
une façon de régler d'améliorer la
sécurité routière et pas seulement
d'aller piger dans la poche des gens
même si depuis 2009 on a réussi à
récolter des bénéfices de plus de 29
millions de dollars mais qu'en pensent
les automobilistes j'ai pu poser la
question à quelques gens de longueuil
moi moi maintenant je suis un gros
camion mais attend que les gens les
textos jonathan carré manchot jusqu'à
des activistes et oui oui des fois j'ai
passées ici je vais rouler puissamment
ya un vélo tu vas pas ses pieds
si je coule un peu plus vite que la
normale a maintenant je vais peut-être
paul delhoume fait que moi je pense
vraiment d'accord de plein de gens le
quai pas sur les jaunes orange puis non
salées ralenti c'est tant mieux mais il
y avait certains endroits là qui était
controversée je pense à celui sur
l'autoroute 15 à la hauteur de la
toiture ce n'est davantage des machines
à sous que des éléments pour la sécurité
routière
ben écoute aux chiffres on l'est
justement ce radar photo seulement l'un
sur l'autoroute 15 à la sortie d'à toi
toi en 2014 c'est humain
plus de 31000 constat plus de 4,6
millions de dollars récoltés pourquoi
souhaitons l'enlever et pensée du
ministre parce qu'on s'est aperçu et
c'était ma crainte c'est que les
accidents se produisent entre 7 heures
le matin 19 heures le soir et la
majorité des billets étaient donnés en
19h et 7h le matin ce qui fait que cette
configuration de voies rapides
il n'ya pas qu'il y ait pas de bouchon
population les gens à rouler plus vite
l'objectif est évidemment de sécuriser
et de ralentir les gens lorsque des
accidents n'étaient pas atteints j'ai
demandé de le retirer
attention toutefois pour les
automobilistes parce que oui on va leur
retirer mais ya pas encore de date
précise et d'ici là il reste en fonction
pour les oiseaux les nouveaux
emplacements ils entreront aussi en
fonction graduellement à partir de la
mi-octobre
bon ben quand même celui des toitures ça
reste une bonne nouvelle
merci merci pascal merci